i
a los chicos a noches muchas gracias
señorita ose
gracias chicos muchas gracias por
acompañarnos el día de hoy vamos a
platicar un poquito sobre el control de
la música
y la música en el 2040 vamos a ver qué
va a pasar por lo pronto va a pasar esto
que dice algo así
espero que me ayuden a cantar las letras
ahí si dice algo así
la melodía muy mala suerte en el dinero
buena suerte en el amor
no hago siempre lo que quiero solo hago
lo mejor que puedo
[Música]
conmigo debes sentir miedo yo decido con
el corazón
muy mala suerte en el dinero buena
suerte en el amor
listos ahora se es conmigo dice muy mala
suerte en el dinero buena suerte en el
amor
exacto dice algo así
no hago siempre lo que quiero solo hago
lo mejor que puedo
más o menos arriba conmigo debes sentir
miedo yo decido con el corazón
más o menos
muy mala suerte en el dinero buena
suerte en el amor
hay otra oportunidad otra rola dice
listos yo quiero bajar y subir y subir y
subir lo intente lo intente lo intente
lo intente y fracasé otra oportunidad
hice
yo quiero subir y tú bajar y bajar y
bajar yo quiero bajar y subir y subir y
subir lo intenté lo intente lo intente
lo intente y fracasé
esa es su última oportunidad y dice yo
quiero subir y bajar y bajar y bajar yo
quiero bajar y tú subir y subir y subir
yo intenté lo intenté lo intenté lo
intenté y fracasé
este es última oportunidad y dice yo
quiero subir y bajar y bajar y bajar yo
quiero bajar y subir y subir subir lo
intente lo intente lo intente mente
y fracase
gracias
ese aplauso fue mucho más de lo que
esperaba
[Aplausos]
lo que acabamos de vivir ahorita si
quiero mi clicker dónde está mi clicker
también mi clicker muchas gracias lo que
acabamos de vivir ahorita es como en
antaño en el pasado era la única manera
como podías escuchar música si el humano
no actuaba como dispositivo para
interpretar esa música no había manera
de que otros humanos tirarán parís no sé
si se sintieran tristes o que usaran la
música para su día a día si tú quieres
en el música tienes que decir oye
beethoven oye tchaikovsky
bueno como si hubiera teléfonos en la
que entonces oyes te puedes venir y
puedes interpretar esta música para que
todos la pasemos bien es la única manera
el humano era el dispositivo que
ejecutaba la música para que alguien más
la disfrutará es la única manera más
adelante este maravilloso invento llega
y revoluciona la manera como la gente
escucha música se inventa el vinil sí y
ahora el humano puede controlar cuándo
dónde y qué escucha ahora puedo decir
sabes que me siento triste quiero
escuchar unas rolas de blé un artista
ondeado que ustedes gusten o alguien
triste o me siento muy feliz quiero
poner un disco de equis o ye sale que me
pone de buen humor y que va se fiesta
a través a partir de que el vinil llegó
a existir el ser humano ya tenía control
de la música que escuchaba un momento
mágico otro momento mágico que a mí me
tocó vivir fue el cassette un
dispositivo nuevo que me permite en unos
5 sitios y de este tamaño tener 10 a 12
rolas y llevarme las a donde yo quiera
más adelante es el cd o el compact disc
y ahora no solo me caben 20 las que me
puede llevar a donde yo quiera sino que
aparte se escuchan increíble no una
fidelidad
y yo sigo controlando la música y yo
sigo controlando que escucho eso es lo
que está bien padre o está muy padre de
ese momento que me tocó vivir
le damos fast for war un poquitito hay
por ahí de los noventas y sale este
maravilloso dispositivo que como la
mayoría de ustedes saben es un
reproductor de mp3 que agarro esa magia
musical del cde y la comprimido así lo
hizo chiquitita con una calidad de audio
gente horrible sin embargo si los
audiófilos sabemos de lo que estamos
hablando sin embargo en ese aparatito
mini mini y tal vez mil rolas o 2002
3000 rolas y yo viví mi experiencia
cuando yo tenía una colección así como
de 500 si disque para mí es muchísimo
entonces era muchísimo y mi amigo
alejandro reno donde dejó los amigos de
todo el universo de mi ciudad natal de
mexicalli
me acuerdo que llegó súper emocionado
con su ipod monocromático blanco con su
pantalla blanco y negro hacia horrible
este y me dijo oye carnal
necesito que me prestes unos y this way'
y los voy a pasar a mi ipod digo claro
way o sea yo te press unos cuantos
quieres no tengo 500 brown sé cuánto
necesitas me dice necesito todos
todos y si sea frente a mis ojos jarro
mis 500 sedes los metió a su dispositivo
y se los llevó a su casa y se me hizo
mágico no sé ahora puedo escoger toda
esta música cuando yo quiera a la hora
que yo quiera en base a cómo me siento
yo tengo el control total sobre esta
música y ese momento fue increíble ahora
llegamos un poquito más adelante a este
dispositivo que todos ustedes estoy
dispuesto a apostar un millón de dólares
traen en sus bolsillos espero que lo
traigan en modo avión smartphone si
nuestro nuevo mejor amigo mío y ustedes
en el cual gracias a la tecnología
gracias
plataformas digitales caben 30 millones
de canciones aquí justo en mi mano más
de 30 millones de canciones se está
increíble o sea yo tengo aquí todas las
rolas que pudiera querer escuchar en mi
vida o en más vidas no sé todo lo que
quiero hacer como helado para escoger
obviamente tengo mis gustos
sé que me gusta este sé qué bandas me
gustan sí pero de repente este mágico
dispositivo que hace yo lo sigo
controlando yo humano siguió controlando
este dispositivo sin embargo ese mágico
dispositivo y esas mágicas plataformas
digitales me sugieren
con base a lo que yo le di like o con
base a lo que yo he escuchado
recientemente me sugieren que escuchar
ese increíble se lo agradezco gracias
smartphone a veces no sé qué escuchar
estoy seguro que se les pasa lo mismo no
sé qué escuchar el smartphone
recomiéndame algo y les recomienda algo
está increíble ahora hace poco toque en
un tributo timbiriche que subo muy
divertido aunque no es mi banda favorita
lo respeto mucho nos están viendo erick
beni saya me encantan pero
los escuché tanto tanto que ahora mi
dispositivo piensa que me encanta esa
banda
sí y me sugiere no sólo esa banda sino
bandas similares y ni se oye milton te
gustó ti me dice de verdad seguramente
te gustará emanuel seguramente te
gustará luis miguel
entonces me recomienda que escuche esas
bandas aunque lo escuché por equis o ye
no lo escuché más que para ensayar y
como se podrán dar cuenta mi teléfono me
conoce tan bien que sabe que soy un
maldito ególatra y me escucho todo el
día si estamos en milton le sugiero que
te escuche es más carnal sí ahí está te
sugiero que te escuchen más y se me
encargó el ego acaso porque amo nisman
sólo hablo si a veces los que escuchar a
veces me siento triste a veces me siento
con ganas de fiesta y a veces no tengo
ganas de pensar
en qué música voy a poner y por eso mi
dispositivo me hace el favor de sugerir
me dice bien con tu tranquilo carnal si
yo te voy a sugerir que necesitas algo
para madrugar cómo te sientes se sientes
libre quieres un cafecito y unas ruedas
con piano me dice que necesitas
milton y se más increíble es lo máximo a
veces quiero limpiar mi casa
no es cierto no la quiero limpiar nunca
pero si la quisiera limpiar que quisiera
música para que me acompañe en ese
proceso ahí está sí sí quiero fiesta y
no quiero pensar en qué música poner ahí
está pues me dispuesto me está
sugiriendo que poner en mi playlist
favorito en todo el universo si me
quiero poner a trapear bien agustín
pues aquí está al parecer selena me
permitiría trapear bien agustín no yo no
sé es el dispositivo el que no está
sugiriendo y te honestamente se me hace
mágico es ahorita este es el presente
viviendo ahorita y se me es un momento
increíble para estar vivo se me hace un
momento
portman melómano que soy y por más que
me encanta tener discos y todo este
momento hoy en día es mágico para la
música y mágico para los músicos y para
el usuario es increíble ahora vamos al
siguiente nivel cuántos de ustedes
corren por las mañanas digamos no duele
saltar la mano yo como si yo corriera
por las mañanas en realidad no lo hago
pero para efectos de esa conferencia
necesito decirlo bueno
michelle mi esposa amada que anda por
allá arriba ella corre casi todos los
días y ella sabe qué problema representa
cuando vas corriendo
stacks más corriendo pasa el tiempo de
la rola inevitablemente sus stocks y
repente que pasa llega el break de la
rola el puente para los conocedores no
hong kong te saca de tiempo es increíble
te saca del ritmo que llevabas no se te
enfocas en la música y no puedes ir
corriendo y eso te odio dispositivo pero
como es el futuro como somos una nueva
era ahora mi dispositivo lee el ritmo de
mi corazón
lee cuantos pasos voy y ya no se para
hay unas aplicaciones que me permiten
correr y mi dispositivo sabe a qué
cuantos beats por minutos voy corriendo
cuantos pasos voy dando y szostak schunk
saxon stacks y cuando llega el puente de
esa rola si en vez de bajarse se
mantiene
songs tax y digo gracias dispositivo te
amo porque me lees me entiendes ya me
estás entendiendo hay una simbiosis que
se está creando entre el dispositivo y
el ser humano no necesariamente los
controlando yo nada más ahora él me está
de cierta manera moviendo en un futuro
vámonos al 2040 y es el 2040 de eso se
tratan estas pláticas sí
aquí atrás seguramente es un como
siempre esas cosas apple what's the
smart watch no sé no lo tengo chicos por
cierto sí sé que existe es de mi
compadre de chicho y toni lo tienen por
ahí se les ve brutal pero en un futuro
ya sea este tipo de dispositivo o un
anillo o un
digamos otro tipo cualquier tipo de
dispositivo que pueda ser pegado a tu
cuerpo va a leer tus signos vitales y va
a saber que estás realmente triste
porque va a decir oye te estás apagado o
no y te va a sugerir quieres estar feliz
permíteme yo te puedo poner feliz o
viceversa estás muy alegre de tu ritmo
cardíaco tus signos vitales me dicen que
estás muy alegre quieres estar abajo
quieres que te deprimas yo te de primo
carnal yo pongo lo que tú quieras
entonces vamos a adelantarnos si llego a
milton pacheco a su casa en el 2040 y mi
dispositivo dice hola milton cómo te
sientes al parecer así no voy a ver o
sea menos vello facial más pelo arriba
va a estar chico este sabes qué
dispositivo del futuro me siento cansado
me siento triste
no sé ha sido un día largo y me va a
decir vamos a cambiar eso
tu dispositivo del futuro si el futuro
mi dispositivo no vende besos y abrazos
porque pues nos amamos no este iba a
saber exactamente qué ponerme hay una
rola de un artista que mike robinson que
me encanta se llama bitch el arte ammac
si me pone de buen humor me encanta esa
canción y el día de hoy vamos a actuar
como si fuéramos ese dispositivo del
futuro si milton pacheco acaba de llegar
2040 triste cansado cansado de trabajar
en paro 1 central de música y todas las
presiones que esto conlleva y mi
dispositivo va a ser esto por mí va a
poner esta canción por mí ahora 2019
todavía no me conoce también a ustedes
me conocen un poquito mejor ya nos
estamos conociendo y necesito que me
ayuden están listos fuera una dinámica
muy interesante ok chicos parados todos
por favor todos arriba muchas gracias
ay les va
de aquí donde está convenientemente
separado aquí abajo para acá van a ser
las voces agudas de aquí para acá si
convenientemente separado no tanto como
ya tiene que más o menos echarle química
vamos a hacer las graves ok entonces
esta bella melodía que me encanta dice
algo así los graves van a decir lo
siguiente listos y un la acción mí
y el aissami
una vez más y el likes en mí
y cuarta vez y lights en mí
y mis agudos por acá van a decir y el
aissami
el aissami
y un lunch en mí
para más y un lunch m
algo en mí
y un hacha mí
todos juntos
a la segunda parte de esta mágica rola
de matt harrison que se llama visión por
cierto y dice
richard además
misión
y uno del audi park
dicción
[Música]
richard m
no teman
y uno de los vivac
todos
aquí listos todos juntos digan el edad
1 2 3 4
y así los empiezo a controlar
yo juego con tu cerebro
ahora yo controlo lo que dices
así que sí o sí que sí sí sí
[Música]
o lo más
excelente chicos pueden tomar asiento
muchas gracias un aplauso para ustedes
ahora
qué pasó ahora el dispositivo del futuro
está controlando mis emociones dimos un
una vuelta completa si 180 grados más
bien vuelta completa es ilógico 180
grados
giuliano control del dispositivo 2040 el
dispositivo empieza a controlar en mí un
poco ahora me preocupa esto estuvo mal
ese ejercicio todos sabemos que en
antaño si no han usado música para
alterar a gente y hacerlos hacer cosas
malas si después un método no es bueno
es algo así brutal y desde en ganas de
no matar y asesinar no quiero usar esas
palabras porque ha sido muy positivo
todo es ahorita pero se puede usar para
el mal o viceversa se puede usar para el
bien para poner a todo mundo de buen
humor si eso es lo que yo quisiera para
el futuro de la música
sean si esto va a pasar no en realidad
no me importa si esto va a pasar el
futuro
no estoy seguro la mera verdad lo único
que sé es que me encanta vivir el
presente estoy ansioso por ver cómo
vamos a escuchar música en el futuro
y como músico y como persona estoy
agradecido de tener este momento estoy
agradecido con ustedes por escucharme y
estoy muy emocionado por saber qué va a
pasar en el futuro lo único que quiero
hacer llegar en ese futuro bailando y
cantando y fokker como diría mi compadre
david bowie
let's dance
muchas gracias